man to my right who I will stop talking
about as if he's not sitting here a
former law I guess you're still a
photographer for Vanity Fair turned
interviewer good to see you Sam Jones
thanks for having me
what when did you realize you know what
I'd like to get out from behind the
camera and sit on camera and talk to
people instead of taking their picture
would you come up with that one well you
know a lot of people know me as a
photographer but I've also directed a
lot and made a few documentaries and
insurance I always enjoy the
conversations that take place either
either in the documentary format or even
just the conversations that were taking
place when I was photographing people
and I always came away from those jobs
with a more complete picture of the
person I was working with and and those
are the conversations that excite me
about being an artist excite me about
creative projects and and so I think
that the idea for the show started is
can you make a complete portrait of an
artist and really get inside their
creative paths and the decisions they
made that led them here because for me I
was always incredibly intimidated when I
met one of my heroes like how did they
how did they do this what did they have
that I don't have or something like that
who is one of those people well I mean
anyone from you know you take a
filmmaker like Hal Ashby or or a
photographer like Richard Avedon or a
skateboarder like Tony Hawk
or you know a songwriter like Joe
Strummer from The Clash or something and
these people were making the work that
that made me want to be an artist and
made me want to do different things and
and the conversations are a way for me
to humanize these people and find out
that they struggled and they made
mistakes and and their creative path is
unique to them and there's no one way to
do it and and I think by having these
conversations it it it gives me it gives
me license to to take risks on my own
and and I'm lucky enough that the thing
I would love to do anyway I get to do as
a show sure so that was the idea and
it's we've been really lucky well I I
could sense when I I said you know
you're a Vanity Fair photographer turned
interviewer and then
mention your directing or whatever I
that that I didn't give the full scope
of the breadth of your work before you
know sitting down in the and I got the
same thing I feel the same way and
that's the reason why I'm doing this
show every day is I don't want you to be
viewed as a traffic cop Sports host
where I have analysts a say something
analyst B say something and then I throw
it a commercial break or let's go out
here like I love this style of show that
I get to interview folks like you and
and and be able to have a voice that's
why Joe Buck is doing undeniable I mean
the guy calls Super Bowls World Series
but he's still sitting down to have
these conversations and right
stretching legs in a way that I really
love and that's part of the reason why I
enjoy watching your show I could see how
you are you know using your past
experiences to to stretch your legs a
little bit very much so and if you look
at the guests that we have on the show
they're awesome by the way they're all
over the place and we've we're very
lucky that though we get people to come
down to our little studio and do this
because yeah there's some people on
there that I I can't believe that we
have on and we do but if this may be one
common denominator about them is that
they're very restless creative people
they don't do one thing you know usually
you'll find that the people we have on
the show most if they've in addition to
being an actor they've written a book or
in addition to playing in a band they've
they've acted or they've directed or and
and those people that that sort of take
risks and stretch their legs as you say
yes are the ones that I think make for
the most fascinating conversations about
process and about creativity because
because they're they're not just you
know they're not just staying in a
comfort zone they're there they're
making themselves uncomfortable on
purpose because that's more exciting Sam
Jones have off-camera it's Sam Jones
here on the Rich Eisen show I get asked
this question all the time I find it
difficult to answer but I'll ask it to
you anyway who's the one who's where the
guests you've enjoyed interviewing the
most getting to meet the most Sam
gosh that it's so hard to to narrow it
down but I will say I've been able to
interview some of my heroes from from my
boyhood you know pursuits I've had Tony
Hawk on
and I grew up and still skateboard to
this day and I it was my passion as a
kid I wanted to turn pro mm-hmm but you
know that didn't happen but I've had
Ricky Carmichael on who is the greatest
motocross racer of all time and that's
another one of my hobbies and something
I love I've had John Doe from X on and
his band introduced me to punk rock and
and then I've had guys like you know
Matt Damon and Robert Downey who who are
you know impossible it's impossible to
understand how they do what they do and
so fascinating to talk to you so kind of
you know people like that are incredible
and one of my early guests was Aimee
Mann who I think is a totally
underappreciated treasure of a
songwriter I agree with you the Magnolia
soundtrack is one of its incredible
soundtracks and and I'm such a big fan
of hers and and to hear her story and to
see what she went through to get to that
place those things are fascinating for
me so so you know we had Tony Hawk here
unlike you I'm not a skateboarder so he
he put me on love too late no no it is
too late I got on one and I absolutely
right out just landed right on my ass is
there video of that there it is take a
look at it the screen right there look
yeah don't laugh too hard
mr. Wilson that's what he it's so
embarrassing Tony Hawk host of all time
and he probably felt terrible see maybe
I should do you know a show in black and
white where I don't have to do anything
physical like you and maybe I should do
this show where I could skate around the
stage you can do that we get the explore
the studio space to use the Christopher
Walken lon we're clearly in the wrong
look at you do a very good show and I'm
enjoy what I'm doing right here I think
we're good and that for what do you have
now let's explore this a little bit more
about music here which one of these Rock
and Roll Hall of Famers would you that
are being nominated here do you think
they all deserve their nomination Sam
that's that's tough because the Rock and
Roll Hall
we look different if if I was putting
the bands in but my tastes I admittedly
lean towards a little more you know a
little less mainstream I would say Nina
Simone definitely belongs in there and
and she's amazing but but you know some
of my favorite bands that changed my
life are nowhere near the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame and that kills me because I
wouldn't put it I wouldn't you know I
think it seems like record company
people decide what goes in the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame and maybe not total
music lovers you are not so you're
saying this corner it's a quarter it's
corporate it's a corporate award like
many and eventually I think they
probably get it right on on a on one
level but you know the Pixies The
Replacements big star the mc5 the Jam
and these bands mmm
you know they're amazing to me and they
also you know they they didn't get
played in the radio they you know so for
me it's I don't really pay that much but
you choose Radiohead over over Bon Jovi
yes I would yeah you know heartbeat huh
in a heartbeat I don't know about that
again I'm from New York City I mean I
mean if you want to talk Jersey you talk
Springsteen you talk Bon Jovi and you
talk about Tony Soprano
that's all I'm sure sells and that's
they're all they're all in the same that
might be your Mount Rushmore of New
Jersey well Sinatra obviously yeah Fred
I'd have been a great guy for you to
interview if he watches Yeah right
he turned 102 of the other day by the
way he's unavailable though yeah he's uh
the good news is he's been he hasn't
well I once there's always that joke
about people have been dead for a while
but I could say the good news they
haven't touched drugs there you go I
like it there you go
yeah good Sinatra last one for you who
would you want to have on your show who
would you who have you not had on that
you'd love to sit down with and have a
conversation with Sam you know funny
enough I would say Vin Scully and we
tried for years we tried you know from
the very first season and I grew up in
Southern California and I used to think
I was a Dodger fan
I am and I call myself but I really was
a Vin Scully fan and and he not only got
me through years of you know when life
was very stressed and full of struggle
right his voice at the end of the day
you know was was the greatest thing for
me but he also managed to turn baseball
into a literary and a more human sort of
poetic experience for me yeah that for
someone who was into skateboarding and
motorcycles and things growing up I
ended up really loving baseball because
of him
he are the greatest storytellers of all
times right because not only would he
tell you stories about what is playing
out in front of you in real time and
describe it as if it was like The
Princess Bride right reading from a book
that he's making up as he goes along or
he would tell stories about something
that happened 50 years ago that is
germane to the play that just happened
and nobody will ever do this again
have a broadcast where they blow off two
commercial breaks just to have a solo
guy or woman in the booth turn around
tell a story for 60 seconds before
returning to the action like Vin Scully
did don't we'll never see that again Sam
I know and you know what you know drives
me crazy is that when he was retiring
and all these people in the sports world
came out saying how amazing he was and
you know Joe Buck says come anytime and
take over the microphone and everybody
loves him and yet I don't see a lot of
sports announcers emulating him not not
to imitate but to but take this idea
that it that we don't want to hear an
expert talk about statistics we'd rather
hear a story we'd rather hear a human
analogy about the game we would rather
hear how this game relates to something
in literature you know what I mean we've
already told the story I'll be honest
with you and uh part of it might be that
if you tried that you might hear from
somebody and management saying what are
you doing I'm I swear to you and you and
you know that's funny and they talk
about wanting
figure out ways to make the game quicker
to make a baseball game shorter yeah and
I would say you know when Vin Scully was
calling it I had always wanted to be
longer interesting and when that was
happening I was in my 20s well Sam like
I said I'm a big fan of your show off
camera with Sam Jones you've got great
guests on coming up this season Willem
Dafoe Rebecca Hall Jeff Daniels Sam
Rockwell Octavia Spencer I did notice
you had Dan Patrick as a guest so as far
as I'm concerned you're missing one we
have a we have a one former ESPN
employee per decade limit really yeah
Berman called okay and pals called okay
well he's he's still there so I guess I
got to wait for season 19 of off-camera
Sam Jones Gannon currently in its ninth
season check out Neil Patrick Harris
next Monday to come back any time Sam
thank you for having you back
you bet right back at you so Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience